now more than ever people from around
the world are becoming aware of the
legitimate mysteries and unanswered
questions related to our lost ancient
past as there are certain ancient
anomalies that are still totally
unexplainable or make no sense even in
the year 2022
you see it's examples such as the
unbelievably massive 100 plus ton
megalithic blocks that make up the stone
walls of sausage woman peru
a perplexing construction of thousands
of perfected polygonal shaped stone
appearing as if they were created and
fit together with laser-like precision
and make no mistake this is indeed a
true mystery as no one can fully explain
much less demonstrate how the known
tooling possessed by the ancients of
south america could have cut
carved moved lifted and constructed
these walls to completion but when it
comes to legitimate ancient mysteries we
should also look at some of the ancient
sites that not only make no sense but
that so few people are even aware of
for example the ancient inca site of
oyante tombo located in the peruvian
andes is certainly recognizable by
people from all over the world with its
notably impressive terraces that have
been geoengineered into the side of this
stunning mountainous landscape
however it's the lesser-known details of
this site that is a complete and total
mystery particularly what sits at the
top of it what you're seeing here are
six 50-ton megalithic granite blocks
that make up the wall of the so-called
temple of the sun
these stones are more than 11 feet tall
and are fitted together with
unbelievable precision and all around
this area you'll find numerous random
blocks that are simply gigantic and
range from 30 to 40 tons apiece
clearly the remnants of whatever once
existed at this site prior to its
obvious destruction which i'll discuss
later in the video but between the
unique shape and design of these stones
it's apparent that what we're seeing
today is significantly different from
its original form to the point that
what's remaining is all but
unrecognizable as it has been repeatedly
recycled built upon and restored by
those who came after
however these random and exceptionally
heavy stone blocks are not even the
largest that exist at this already
impressive ancient site
what you're seeing here is an
approximately 80 ton granite block
so large that it's difficult to capture
a full photo of it as it's been blocked
by another massive stone and the area
directly in front of it is roped off and
the guys who work at this site strictly
prohibit anyone from crossing the
barrier
however you can get an idea for its
incredible length when viewing it from
behind as you can see here and i took
most of these photos myself while
visiting peru last august
but i did find this photo on google
which shows a bit more of it and
thankfully compared to people
i do not know the specific dimensions of
this stone but i estimated that it is
perhaps 20 to 30 feet in length or 6 to
9 meters and again one solid piece of
stone
make no mistake this thing is an
absolute behemoth and that brings us to
the awkward fact that this is indeed an
unexplainable ancient relic because the
unanswered question is how do the
ancients get stones of this magnitude to
the top of a mountain and it gets crazy
once you learn where these granite
blocks actually came from now this is me
standing to the left of those six blocks
that make up the so-called sun temple as
i showed you a moment ago and you see
that rocky peak there
that is the location of the quarry to
which these stones came from and the
picture does not do the size of this
mountain justice as that peak is a mile
higher in elevation from where i'm
standing and get this it is nearly two
and a quarter miles ground distance away
in other words these 30 40 50 and 80 ton
stone blocks were brought nearly one
mile down a steep mountain and then
immediately carried across a river
that's right where you see that line of
trees down at the base of the mountain
is a river from which these massive
stones were somehow carried across and
then transported through the valley to
where they were then somehow carried a
few hundred feet up a steep hill to
where they now lay
so here's another question how many of
you are hearing about these significant
details for the first time because
although we could probably conclude that
these stones would have been likely
pushed and then tumbled down to the
bottom of the mountain from the quarry
i'm still not so sure that would be the
method as it seems to me that stones or
boulders of this size would likely
fracture and break apart in a fall like
that who knows but let's be real to even
push just one stone block of this size
off of a cliff would be no easy feat but
that aside for me the big question is
how did they carry 50 and 80 ton stones
across a river and then hundreds of feet
up a steep hill
to truly appreciate the type of weight
that we're discussing here we have to
put it all into perspective
80 tons is equivalent to 160 000 pounds
or 72 500 kilograms in other words that
180 ton stone is closer to double the
weight of the most common airliner in
the world the boeing 737 which i'm sure
all of us or most all of us recognize
but let's compare it to a tank the
latest update to the m1a2 abrams is now
even heavier and weighs in at 73 tons
this thing squashes nearly everything it
runs over into a pancake and by the way
it's worth mentioning that this picture
is of when it was only 60 tons so three
quarters of the weight of that one 80
ton stone
but let's make a more practical
comparison
one of the top five most popular cars on
earth is the toyota camry which is an
average size family sedan and weighs
approximately 3 500 pounds or one and
three quarter tons in other words that
one 80 ton stone is equivalent to more
than 45 of those cars and yet that one
stone's total surface area is only a few
times larger than one of those cars
think about that it paints us a picture
for just how mind-bogglingly dense and
heavy granite actually is it's almost
unimaginable for our brains to genuinely
comprehend it
so with all of that in mind the next big
question becomes
why would they go to such extreme extent
to choose a very specific type of
granite that is found all the way over
at that quarry instead of using the
existing stone that makes up the
mountain of oliante tombow and by the
way you'll notice that the same volcanic
stone that makes up this mountain was
already used for various stone blocks
around this site
so why would they choose to go to such
extreme extent for this particular
structure
because i have to say that i am not at
all convinced that they did so for the
purpose of having some aesthetically
pleasing change of color for this
alleged temple
but if all of that wasn't interesting
enough wait until you hear this
the accepted theorized explanation for
how the ancients would have moved these
massive stones was said to be with the
use of ropes pulleys and also by rolling
the stones over tree logs to get them
from point a to point b
for example it's been suggested that the
eucalyptus tree would have been used to
do that as it is abundant in peru and
these trees grow tall and straight
reaching heights of 180 feet and
remarkably fast in fact they can grow to
100 feet in just 10 years alone
but here's the issue with that the
eucalyptus tree is not native of south
america and was brought from australia
in the mid and latter part of the 1800s
most people are not aware of this and it
actually wasn't even until the 1970s
that the peruvian government
orchestrated the widespread creation of
eucalyptus forests to help their
citizens have access to firewood and for
creating infrastructure
so no the eucalyptus tree was not
utilized by the ancients to move stone
blocks as some have suggested
and this is a significant detail when
you consider that the largest native
tree of peru of course excluding the
trees found in the amazon rainforest
which borders peru on the other side of
the andes mountains but the largest tree
native in this area is a quinoa
definitely mispronouncing that uh so
forgive me but here's the thing
this tree does not grow any higher than
4 meters or 13 feet but not only that
its trunks never grow straight as you
can see for yourself this is a
relatively small tree and the very
nature of the shape that it grows could
not have at all been conducive for
rolling massive stone blocks or for
rolling anything else for that matter
you see this is what i'm talking about
it's not until you investigate the more
nuanced details that you can fully
appreciate just how much of a mystery
we're dealing with here
and something else that's very
interesting to mention is that there are
clearly multiple types of stonework at
this site at least three in fact yet
academics claim that this was all done
by the same people and at the same time
and they suggest that the ancients must
have simply changed their construction
patterns as they grew tired of working
with the larger stones and so they
transitioned to smaller yeah i'm sorry
but that's clearly not the case at least
in my opinion like i always say look and
think for yourself and keep in mind that
they also claim that this structure
wasn't destroyed either but rather just
wasn't completed
um okay well that's not what i saw when
i was there especially when you consider
this site as a whole as there are
numerous massive stones that were found
at the base having been clearly fallen
from far above likely related to some
powerful earthquake which of course are
common in the peruvian andes i mean
just look clearly something devastating
happened here
even some of the larger or more
impressive stones were clearly broken
apart and it's odd that they're so
randomly placed and again you also have
to imagine these giant stones without
the crude smaller ones that were
obviously filled in later and also
observed just how bizarrely shaped and
designed larger granite stones are
clearly purposeful
the unique cuts within them were
obviously designed with intention and
had some type of function
perhaps support for other structures
that would have been built
around them or you know remnants that
have long since gone
and some will even suggest that this was
for you know carrying them but why is it
that so many of the other stones don't
have any of those features at all
ultimately i want to see a modern
demonstration of a large stone block
being moved up a steep hill with the use
of the alleged primitive methods that
the ancients were said to have used but
let me first share something interesting
that goes along with that which is that
this was allegedly demonstrated hundreds
of years ago but with completely
disastrous results in graham hancock's
book fingerprints of the gods he cites a
500 year old example that was written
about by garcilaso de la vega in his
book titled the royal commentaries of
the incas where he describes how people
long ago attempted to carry one massive
stone uphill in order to restore the
massive blocks of sausage woman
to do this they utilized 20 000 men to
move this one stone several
miles uphill only for it to end in
disaster when they lost control of it
and it tumbled down and killed some 3
000 men
unreal now this is of course anecdotal
but i don't really see any reason to
doubt it perhaps some of the figures of
how many men attempted it or were killed
may be exaggerated or inaccurate but it
seems to me that something catastrophic
did take place for de la vega to
document it in his book
again this is why it is so important for
our modern suggested or alleged
primitive theories
should be tested and demonstrated it's
easy to just develop theories on what
type of manpower would be necessary to
accomplish these awesome feats but it's
another to actually do it so my response
to anyone who will hear this video and
still adamantly claim that the ancients
of south america simply use ropes to tug
these 80 ton stones up mountains and
transport them over logs and over rivers
you really need to share a video
demonstration proving that these methods
are actually feasible all of that said
this still doesn't take into account
other profoundly unexplainable ancient
sites from around the world whether it
be balbac and lebanon
certain sites in ancient egypt or even
the 125 tonne stone at sacse woman which
i shared earlier in this video
definitely leave a comment and share
your thoughts on all of this and how you
think the ancients could have done it
and what your thoughts are on the
so-called temple of the sun at the top
of yante tombo
but all that said i'll close it up here
my name is jimmy corsetti my channel is
called bright insight hit the like
button and subscribe and again leave a
comment share your thoughts on all of
this and i have another fascinating
video to come real soon thanks for
watching take care everyone